now here is the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and they were
running cover for fettermen like you
wouldn't believe
I think it's also really interesting you
played a lot of Clips there were moments
where he was really strong including
that Bernie Sanders clip including his
very fluent and direct response on
raising the minimum wage I thought was a
really strong moment for him he had some
really really strong comebacks and and
his opponent Oz was first of all he also
fumbled right I fumble on television
right so it's there is I definitely I
was nervous and hesitant at first too
yeah I mean this it just happens right
um but Oz also was really slippery and
he and it's such pure deflection and
projection uh no you can watch go back
guys like if you feel like it if you're
not doing much today you can watch
unedited the full hour it's a disaster
for fetterman there really were no good
moments and this idea that some people
fumble that Oz fumbled look I do a show
that is live every single day I do
fumble over things sometimes sometimes
even if I'm looking in the prompter and
and we're not totally lined up I start
going off on a tangent and Phoenix has
to catch up with me but everything I say
is off the top of my head so
occasionally I'm going to mess up a word
I'm going to Bumble or stumble or
whatever but that's not what we're
talking about here the idea that Oz did
anything close to what fetterman did is
completely ridiculous but this is what
they do they run cover for these people
while then attacking us she was also
implying that Oz was being mean about
fetterman's condition which simply
wasn't true uh and it's just people can
see it people can see it